I'm Trevor Phillips this is Common
Ground where each week we look for
agreement on a hot button issue dividing
the nation tonight
controlled migration has benefited the
UK economically socially and culturally
but when immigration gets out of control
it places great pressure on our society
economy and public services I'm in favor
of immigration
but I'm also in favor of control
conversation in Stoke-on-Trent is not
about where the GDP is up by 0.1 percent
per annum because of an open border
policy it is about quality of life there
is such a thing as too much immigration
and such a thing as too little
immigration and yes the optimal level
will be different at different times and
no calculating it may not be an exact
science
we should use our Newfound control to
deliver the kind of migration that grows
our economy for example that helps
projects that have stalled or built
friendships and relationships with our
allies
economic growth is emerging as
everyone's favorite remedy to inflation
inequality and inadequate investment not
least the Prime Minister and the
chancellor
yet there are hundreds of thousands of
jobs vacancies and nobody to fill them
employers say they just can't get the
staff unless we open the doors to more
economic migrants
but there's an old saying we ask for
workers and people K who need homes
health care and education and that costs
it's an argument that has divided the
nation for half a century does
prosperity come with more immigration or
less
our choice squeeze more from an aging
low productivity population and risk
stagnation if we fail
or open the doors to Young skilled
immigrants whatever the cost in Social
cohesion and pressure on public services
in the next 30 minutes we go in search
of common ground
[Music]
with me tonight Vicki price chief
economic advisor to the Center for
economics and business research and the
former head of the government economic
service
and from Conservative Party Conference
in Birmingham Robert Colville director
of the center for policy studies who was
a co-author of the 2019 conservative
Manifesto
um let me start with you Vick if I may
um we already have historically high
levels of inward migration over 700 000
this year
um
why do we need more people to support
economic growth well the most important
thing to look at is the net migration
how many people have also gone so the
numbers are not that great when you look
at that we're talking about possibly
over two hundred thousand forty thousand
yes uh so the interesting thing is we've
been getting roughly that number now for
you know a couple of decades frankly yes
there was a brief period when we were
getting more after uh there was this big
influx of people from um particularly
the former Eastern European countries
but that then became sort of quite
normalized if you like well the reason
why it matters is first of all it
increases the labor force that we have
and that's good news because if you want
to get growth of any sort you need an
increasing labor force or a very
substantial increase in productivity or
both
since productivity hasn't done
particularly well in this country I
think increasing the labor force is
absolutely important without that growth
will stall very significantly and we
benefited from that hugely in all sorts
of different ways because migrants
generally pay more tax than they receive
in benefits so they're actually net
contributors to the fiscal side of of
the balance sheet if you like they're
bringing skills they allow huge
flexibility in the economy and just
going back to the productivity point
they also do contribute to productivity
because generally the highest skill than
the population on average
okay well let's let's come back to some
of those points particularly
productivity Point
um Robert uh
if we don't import engineers and uh
doctors and so on as you know Vicki's uh
hinting uh the productivity issues and
all that aside
um how do we
actually create growth how do we avoid
stagflation and just becoming if you
like Japan at its worst
well I think the immigration has
benefited the country hugely
um there are many of us myself included
who wouldn't be here without him
immigration but there's a danger that uh
that sometimes it becomes something of a
of a shell game Vicky said that uh
immigration raises GDP and that's right
but obviously you know GD in part GDP is
just a product of the number of people
who are here
um essentially our economy for the last
couple of decades got got hooked on
cheap migration it became it became
dependent on a high level of migration
in all sorts of areas and you saw this
after the brexit vote when the
government was trying to clamp down on
um on immigration sector after sector
would go to the government and say look
uh yeah we know we know we know we know
you need to restrict immigration we know
we need greater control but but we are a
special case there are specific skills
that we cannot access in the British
economy that we need to import and you
know and in many cases obviously in some
cases that was special feeding but in
many cases it was absolutely right there
are all sorts of sort of tiny brought
next all over the economy in terms of
skills I I mean I'll give an example
from uh from the city and the and the
financial and the sort of startup sector
if you talk to people who are leading
sort of fast-growing companies they say
you know there are specific skills
around a You Know Chief Finance officers
Chief Revenue officers um very very sort
of quite technical um things that a
fast-growing startup needs where you
need to be able to attract Talent from
from America or from South Africa or
wherever it may be likewise up here in
Birmingham if you talk to the
politicians it may sound like a cliche
but they would say that you know they
need to get to get professional Curry
chefs in uh from from other countries in
order to keep that that part of their
economy going
okay let's let's delve into each of
these cases in a bit more start seeing
um with the case that you put for Vicky
um some people say this is the lazy way
to growth that actually what we should
focus on is more investment increasing
skills all of that and actually the more
you bring people in the more you put off
the evil day so for example you get more
uh chefs from Bangladesh instead of
teaching some young kids to become chefs
perhaps I think some of those things
cannot probably be taught but just doing
it here I'm guessing hence why there is
a need for more chefs from Bangladesh to
come and I think that's probably not
going to go away in in a hurry but there
is no doubt that we do need to train
people more and we do need to improve
the skills that we have right now if you
look at the UK Itself by comparison to
oecd countries we seem to spend less in
terms of the amount of money that goes
into training employees than most other
City countries with the exception of
health and safety where we really go
overboard on that so we could do hugely
better there's no doubt about that but
what immigration does is it allows this
extra flexibility it allows companies to
expand because if you imagine that
you've only got a certain amount of of
you know people at work or people you
can call on then obviously anyone who
comes in and invests here in order to
expand and sell to Europe or sell to
anywhere else wants to be absolutely
certain that there is this flexibility
of Labor it can bring in labor when it
needs to get rid of it when it doesn't
need to and what we saw through the
membership of the EU was that this
flexibility was incredibly useful
because people could come and people
could go and the interesting thing is
right now if you look at migration net
migration in Europe we should into the
UK the net part of it if you like coming
and going it's actually zero okay and
which is an extraordinary thing and they
were the ones who were providing us if
you like with this with this breathing
space and providing the companies with
brainlyspace that's gone Robert um what
what do you say to this basic point that
actually part of the role of immigration
is it's not just a straight static uh
equation but actually it's partly the
lubricant in in the engine of growth
it's true immigration help helps the
economy adjust but the point here is and
the key Point here is that immigration
is not just about economics I mean
that's why we had the the brexit votes I
mean it's one of the main drivers of the
brexit vote that's why there was such a
panic over the um over the channel
Crossings this year and last people you
know immigration has has cultural and
social elements as well in in particular
in terms of the the demand for public
service the demand for for housing so I
mean our Think Tank uh the center for
policy studies has been campaigning uh
zealously for more house building and
one of the things you always hear people
tell you is yeah but you know it it's
just it's just because of our
immigration that you know there's a
there's a link in quite a lot of
people's minds between you know between
sort of nimbyism and and immigration and
in fact we ran the numbers and um you
know a significant chunk of the extra
demand for housing though by no means
all of it and actually in fact binomial
is the majority is down to extra numbers
coming in and there's also the the
cultural assimilation point that people
want to feel that you know that this is
on under control they want to feel that
people coming in are coming are
stimulating they're becoming part of the
society and not being sort of cordoned
off in in separate areas so this there's
this whole complex of other issues and I
think the danger is that we have often
too often just thought about this and
talked about it as if it was an economic
issue solely
Vicky this is um is an important point
isn't it because it it isn't a straight
uh numbers game that there are cultural
questions and there are all sorts of
issues pressures on public service and
and so on um how do you make that some
work I think it's a it's a very
important point and I do agree that
there are stresses that come into
particular communities when there are
lots of people turning up from wherever
they may be turning up but it is really
interesting first of all what you find
is that uh if you look at the Historical
sort of migration uh details um people
who come from the EU tend to be already
educated and they are single people
possibly who come in work and do not for
some time bring any family along and
they go back
people who come from non-eu countries
tend to also bring their family so if
you look at the Visas that have been
granted quite a lot of the Visas over
the last year have been for family
members so be able to join others so
what you find is that there can be
different types of migration that one is
talking about but if you look though for
those who come for work the interesting
thing about the fact that yes perhaps
they may be asking for some services but
we know that overall they ask for fewer
Services as a native born because they
were born somewhere else the National
Health Service of their system dealt
with them they were Educators somewhere
else a very large percentage come with
tertiary education already we haven't
had to provide that either so in fact
overall there is a win
um if you just look at the balance sheet
of that for example yes of course as I
said there are localized issues and it's
absolutely true we're not building
enough houses we should be building more
but this is what you expect from a
growing population
Robert I mean there's some agreement
here that that there is a trade a
trade-off here but um
do you think that actually experience
has demonstrated let's say since uh
2003-2004 the accession and then what's
happened in the last three or four years
that ideally you'd be a I want to come
to the issue of selection of migrants in
a moment but that ideally you'd like to
be able to control it but actually our
experience in the last 20 years is that
in fact we haven't been able to control
numbers by one way or another uh the
numbers have have kept rising to the
point as I said where we've got 700 000
migrants this year net numbers yes but
of course that's a problem because the
the net number stays the same but that
means more people are leaving the
country this is this is a bad spiral
isn't it
well so I I'd half agree with you there
I mean numbers numbers have risen and
that may not be what some of the people
who voted for leave um Wanted and voted
for but they haven't they there hasn't
been a concerted attempt by government
to to restrict the uh the amount of done
the number of people coming in in fact
the opposite Boris Johnson is uh was was
pro-immigration he's actually quite a
quite liberal on these matters um you
know despite um
than any other prime minister
indeed um and yeah as Vicky says what
what changed was the was where those
people were were coming from I mean I I
but I think the um I mean on the issue
she's talking about you know
fundamentally it you know if you bring
in young working age people wherever
they're from they will tend to
contribute it's if you bring in uh if
you're bringing older people or younger
people they will fairly obviously uh be
using public using public services
because you know that's just how how the
age structure works and well it feels me
like we're moving actually to a place
where the two of you might be in the
same place but let me let me test a
couple of things with you I mean both of
you seem to think that if you
essentially got the right kind of
immigrant it would all be fine
um my experience is for example the
Canadians have profited from this but of
course one of the things that has
happened in Canada is that though the
levels of migration are still inward
migration are as high
the people who came to my Canada in the
1980s and 90s would come from Africa the
Caribbean so now it's India in the
Philippines and I think there is an
issue here do you by choosing your
migrants end up essentially
discriminating against some groups of
people because the interesting thing is
if you look across the oecd for example
which is the the advanced economies the
organization for economic cooperation
and development which tracks this what
you find is that indeed in the last
decade or so it's been Asian migrants
have gone everywhere so it's not you
choose your migrants those are the ones
who seem to want to come and who have
the skills which fit well with the
economy you're trying to develop but I
think we mustn't forget that a large
part of migrants you know come to work
yes indeed in the growing sectors where
they have the very skills to do so but
also an equal percentage they come to
work in the declining Industries where
no one wants to work in those sectors in
the economy itself the native if you
like people who are we can consider as
such that I suppose you know the winner
we've been with migrants ourselves
really at least I am certainly I came
from somewhere in Europe
um so but what you find is that a lot of
those migrants come to because we
wouldn't be able to to have anyone
working in those sectors that are our
are diminishing if you like and
important so they have two roles to play
let me put that to Robert I wonder if
Robert from your point of view that
latter point is a problem because
actually uh some people would say that
we use immigration to prop up uh sectors
that we really should get out of
yeah or the classic example is is car
washes where automatic car washes uh you
know a higher productivity form of
washing your car we're replaced by uh by
gangs of people with squeegees um sorry
um out on the um on the streets because
because labor costs were so low I mean
we we've traditionally used you know
immigration basically to Thrill fill
three different kinds of holes I mean
just High skilled um which is you know
people coming into high-flowing jobs in
in a city or wherever low skilled which
is people um washing cars or picking
picking fruits and the the kind of
things that Vicky refers to or um Public
Services uh you know to doctors and
nurses in NHS for example all of those I
think are fairly popular the the problem
came when it was when it when it was you
know the the Baristas in Starbucks the
um uh the the people behind the bow in
the pubs there was a sense that you know
we were filling just the entirely we're
using the immigration to fill the entire
labor market and in terms of where where
people come from um Vicky's right you
know you can't really sort of pick and
choose I mean Jeremy corbyn and and
actually our Young Kia Stormer we're
kind of right on this they their belief
was that in any immigration system was
inherently discriminatory because you
were discriminating against people who
were not born in who who are not born in
the UK in favor of people who were born
in the UK and that that's absolutely
right like that's that's what an
immigration system does but you kind of
for Democratic reasons you have you have
to have that I mean I think one of the
interesting things that's going to
happen over the next few decades is that
the Asian influx is going to be replaced
by an African influx if you look at the
the population pressures in Africa in
countries like Nigeria there is there
are going to be an extraordinary number
of people
um many of whom want to want to come
north to Europe and that's that's kind
of what we're already seeing and they
are young people do you feel like
uncomfortable about that at all that
that the cultural cost that uh Robert
referred to earlier on for example
well not necessarily I mean lots of
people have adapted and uh managed to do
incredibly well in in the UK and I think
one has been able to to assimilate
people of various Origins at various
stages and and people coming really
really determined to work and contribute
I can only and that can only be a
positive uh impact in the UK but we're
not going to be the only ones and they
we think that perhaps you know we stand
out because we had so many people coming
in from Eastern Europe as former Eastern
Europe as was for example and of course
we have the Commonwealth and everyone
who came here through that route but in
reality there are many places in Europe
where which have higher numbers of
non-nationals who've moved in and are
working there you know whether you look
for example in Germany whether you look
at Switzerland where you've really got a
high percentage of people of non-native
origin uh who are there contribute and
and of course they've been various times
when uh you know politically that seemed
to be unsustainable but nevertheless
they're still there well uh we're
talking about this as though the the
problem is really about getting people
to fit in but of course there's the
other side of the this equation which
we've seen
um in Sweden for example and lastly in
Italy where irrespective of whether the
people who turn up want to fit in the
people who are already sitting there
settled
I'm not so Keen so for example Sweden
which had a rather open policy an asylum
now has a substantive substantial
minority of swedes voting for a party
which is nakedly and uncomplicatedly
anti-immigrant we've seen something
similar in Italy um Robert does that
worry you that then this the economic
necessity which I think both of you kind
of accept will lead to a political
challenge that thus far other countries
have failed to uh to meet
I I think that's right I mean we we have
had ukip but but the UK is unusual very
unusual in the European context in not
having a significant
anti as you say a significant
anti-immigrant party at this point and
actually you can make the argument as
people like Fraser Nelson have that
brexit was acted as a safety safety
valve on that that rather than turning
in the UK into a more racist country
it's um it reassured people that um that
their concerns were were being listened
to I mean I think we do have actually a
good story to tell on this I mean we
were talking about people from Africa
you know the common in in the Caba we
have um you know we have quasi quaten we
have kemi badanov we have soella
bravement we have if you compare us to
those Europe to other European countries
we we have done a much better I mean we
have people like Trevor Phillips hosting
uh news we haven't understood yeah
that's one of the things that most
people objectives but simulating
but yeah I mean I was talking to someone
who who who deals with France I mean
France has you know
they're getting better at it but but
historically the French cabinets have
looked incredibly white and Incredibly
male compared to us even though they
have a huge um a huge immigrant
population themselves do you do Vicky
think that I mean I I hear what Robert
says
um but somebody watching this might say
this is a bit complacent because we
haven't had the experience of France Le
Pen Italy Maloney uh the Sweden
Democrats uh true fins all of that why
should we be the only country and Trump
by the way why should we be the only
country that escapes that kind of
backlash well it isn't quite as simple
as that because of course remember
through Europe we had all those migrants
coming after the Iraq war in Syria
particularly after Syria where we've
seen a huge uh influx of of migration
and that course ended up going through
quite a large part of Europe countries
that were objecting even having them you
know come near their border and then on
to Germany and there's been a big
Division if you like
um between the countries S2 you know the
the size you know whether they should
share the migrants in a similar way or
not I think the migration that we've
seen here has been mostly work related
rather than this sort of massive
migration in fact we haven't allowed
quite a lot of those people to come over
to here so the channel has been
protective if if you like so it's one of
the reasons I think while we are quite
different in that respect so so what I'm
feeling here is that for once on on this
program we're having some success in
finding common ground both of you think
that there is a place uh for substantive
migration that we're not as a country
dramatically alarmed by the prospect
that it is part of the uh growth
Prospect what I want to just ask both of
you um before we come to the end though
is that both of you both have also
agreed that we will need to do some
quite serious selection now how do we do
that Vicky
well the businesses of course
businesses no are already putting in
their bids if you like and yes of course
I mean as uh as we've been hearing I
mean the ones who shot loudness may get
their wish if you like and get those
visas uh agreed for their chefs or
whoever else it is that they need I mean
we had that with sgv drivers of course
for a while when we had a serious
serious problem I think economically it
is the private sector that knows where
the issues are but of course we've got a
serious problem in the public sector
health workers for example where we have
this big big gap in terms of the number
of nurses we need doctors we need social
care workers we need so that way of
course can you can determine where the
needs are but they change and you've got
to be very very flexible Robert do you
think we can trust employers
I think we can adjust employees to a
certain extent but I do think um as
Vicki said we need to train more here we
need to train more uh medical star start
staff here in in particular I think we
um you know we we have probably we have
we've probably sort of reached the
limits of the the level of mass
immigration that that people will will
be comfortable with and I think there is
a risk that people who voted leave May
sort of finally notice that immigration
hasn't actually come down and start to
get quite quite worried about that well
but we did say that uh people were
saying that six or seven years ago
Robert they were saying when um uh net
immigration was uh something like a
hundred and something thousand and uh
David Cameron said we've got it down got
to get it down below a hundred thousand
people were saying it's intolerable it's
now quarter of a million and nobody's
writing in the streets
no and that's and that's very that's
very encouraging but I think we need to
keep an eye on it I mean it turned out
we did get it down to tens of thousands
it just took a global pandemic that it's
never crushed International Mobility
uh so uh are you Vicky you're optimistic
that uh uh immigration at this sort of
level we're talking quarter of a million
300 000 is going to be part of the
picture for the future yes but of course
for businesses because we're no longer
in the EU it's much more costly you have
to go through this whole process and pay
and review you know where where you are
and put representations to the
government uh and that's not easy so
that adds to what businesses have to
deal with right now so we are in a
sub-optimal situation but yes we do need
the migrant and Robert the the other
which I asked you if you could trust
employers
um
can we trust the government to be
consistent because of course one of the
things that we're going to need to do if
we have a policy on immigration is to
stick to it you can't do it uh change it
every year and also you can't perhaps
tell people it's going to be this and
then in practice make it something
different
um how how do you think we can make
governments consistent and also honest
about immigration
yeah we absolutely need more consistency
and one of the measures the the well the
Old Government now took um was to create
a more of a sort of real-time monitor of
the uh of vacancies and skills and
shortages which would be could be
plugged directly into the immigration
system which I think is rather than sort
of making laborious decisions about you
know people having to go cap in hand to
the government with every uh
sector-by-sector basis which I think is
important but I think we also need to do
a lot more planning about how we cope
with the concept of immigration I've
been struck by you know we've recently
let in or offered to let in tens of
thousands of ukrainians tens of
thousands of Hong kongers that is a
brilliant those are both brilliant
initiatives everyone should support them
absolutely but many of the same
politicians who are saying let them all
come in we're also saying let's not
build any more houses but obviously if
you're letting tens of thousands of more
people into the country you need to
build houses for them and you need to uh
you know you need to prepare the Public
Services to adapt to that and I think we
need to be a lot uh you know a lot more
strategic about that kind of thing well
well thank you both very much and I'm
very cheerful today because it it feels
as though on what has been historically
the most divisive question in this
country uh we have you know two literate
economically capable intelligent people
who actually agree about this we don't
get that that often and what we seem to
agree is yes economic growth yes uh uh
immigration has to be part of that yes
there has to be some selection yes by
employers but that actually government
by some
some process will actually uh we can
trust government to some extent uh on
this and that uh we can actually see
something happening in this country that
doesn't land Us in the place of Sweden
and Italy uh where extremes come into
Politics on the back of resistance to
immigration well I think we've solved a
big problem between us thank you very
much Robert thank you very much Vicky
stay with us we're going to have all of
today's news coming up after the break
foreign
[Music]